welcome to AI the future of us a podcast
Style video series that explores the
ways AI is shaping our future and how
can how we can prepare for the changes
that liar had I'm your host Farah
techner from Google cloud and today we
are joined by Donna shut who is head of
Applied analytics and AI Solutions at
Google Cloud thank you for being here
today Donna
thanks for having me for it
so could you please tell us a bit about
your background and expertise in the
field of AI
sure
um yeah so actually as of today I lead a
Technical Solutions management team
focused on generative Ai and prior to
this I led applied analytics and AI
Solutions as well as worked in our
Professional Services organization
helping some of our most advanced
customers and actually internal teams as
well build their machine learning
platforms
that's awesome how did you become
interested in Ai and what do you find
the most fascinating about it
yeah so um growing up I played chess at
an international level and that really
sparked my passion for how we design AI
systems to help humans and Alpha zero is
a great example of that so in chess uh
when you evaluate a position you look at
kind of three things material which is
uh their points uh given to Pieces space
and then peace activity and what Alpha
zero essentially did is it changed the
way that we evaluate those three things
so placed more emphasis on space and
peace activity and introduce new
Concepts and that really is a good
example of you know what I love about AI
is that it pushes the boundaries of our
thinking and it can be applied to so
many different uh problems that you're
always learning
wow great I didn't know that actually so
and one of the the funny things I heard
recently is that LMS are not good at
playing chess as well so I'll definitely
you know be catching about you on that
so I want to look into video the
challenges around it you know how we can
close the gaps in between the data and
you know machine learning as well and in
your opinion what are the main oil laps
that you are you see traditionally for
two separate disciplines right so for
data analytics and data engineering and
machine learning based on your
experience
yeah that's a great question
um I think for me it always starts with
a business problem
um so whatever problem that you're
looking to solve first of all it depends
on you know what is the right approach
for that problem it could be analytics
or it could be machine learning and then
as you mentioned um I think we've seen
them traditionally be separated but you
know ideally
um you want a common vocabulary between
those two teams where you know the
business metrics that the analysts are
reporting on are the same as the
features that data scientists use so an
example of that would be for example
conversion ratio within the marketing
domain
um and then I think when you look to
data engineering and uh ml engineering I
think building an ml enabled solution is
an iterative process between data
engineering machine learning engineering
and actually also app engineering where
the ml engineering team really leverages
the data sets and features produced by
the data engineering team and then the
ml engineering team will feedback those
data requirements uh to the data
engineering team so I mean really
machine learning models are only as good
as the data that's provided
thank you and and that that oil up is
you know I I totally agree and just to
expand on that a little bit how do you
see day Tops on ML Ops with llms in mind
evolving in the next few years because
we are seeing a lot of applications we
are selling a lot of new approaches
coming through as well where do you
think that we'll be leading to
yeah
llms really allow for faster
experimentation in many cases without
the need for heavy data preparation
which was needed to train machine
learning models previously
um we're still in the very early stages
of generative AI with many customers
experimenting whereas automation is an
advanced characteristic of a mature
technology and so you know this is still
very much an evolving field
um however we expect generative AI to
take a similar trajectory to traditional
machine learning when you know emerging
machine learning efforts matured into ml
engineering so for example
um we currently see a lot of ad hoc
prompt engineering and very nascent
prompts evaluation and prompt management
processes at the same you know time we
see uh experimental approaches applied
to other methods of model adaptation
like model tuning and this is similar to
the early stages of ml workflow
implementations before the introduction
of Frameworks like tfx and kubeflow we
also already see you know the Divergent
from established mlaps practices to
what's optimal for working with llms you
know most customers will likely adopt
foundational models to their
requirements through prompt engineering
or optimized tuning techniques like
parameter fashion tuning reinforcement
learning from Human feedback you know
distillation where Knowledge from a
larger model can be learned by a smaller
model will become an important aspect of
preparing models for efficient
deployment and serving and then
integration of llm models with external
sources of knowledge will also become a
common pattern so organizations will
need to evolve their mlops processes and
tooling to better accommodate these new
techniques and that's really interesting
insights Stoner and I think we'll be
seeing you know lots of different
personas taking some of the tasks that
you mentioned as well it'll be
interesting to see whether this will
rely on with the data scientists ml
Engineers data analysts or Engineers or
even business analysts as well but you
know I would like to focus on the
challenges on applying and using
generative AI you know according to what
are the examples of how gen AI is
currently being used effectively across
the you know different Industries
because I know for the fact that you
talk to a lot of customers and what are
the what are the things that you are
saying I would like to you know get a
bit more insight on that
yeah
um so I think with generative AI we
entered a new
which is defined by
interaction between humans and
Technology
um and you know areas where we we see a
lot of interest is for example in
marketing so uh being able to very
quickly generate content uh based off of
trends that marketeers are seeing being
able to generate content for audiences
that's much more personalized
um we see it being used in customer
service so for example to create chat
Bots that are more conversational to
their customers or assisting support
agents by you know summarizing their
case notes indicating the next step or
generating an FAQ where they can look up
answers it's helping Engineers by
generating code or you know suggesting
the next lines of code or it can be
through you know a code bot where
developers can talk to and ask questions
or for debugging purposes
so those are a few uh not all
encompassing but it shows you know the
wide range of impact that it can have
I think certainly we'll be seeing lots
of innovative applications in this area
but within that as well you know what
why does it bring to the organizations
right so you know there are lots of
interesting applications coming through
but it's sometimes challenging to
identify where the value relies and and
you know what do you feel around that
yeah
um so I think areas where we've uh seen
it create value is it enhances the
customer experience right so the ability
to reach larger client bases by making
these interactions more natural and
conversational
um improving or you know accelerating
the time to Value so it's easier to
search and understand large amounts of
complex data and then you know assisting
employees or boosting their productivity
so by generating text code image some of
the examples that we just gave very
quickly and multimodually
um
those are a few of the you know areas
where we've seen it create value
and definitely multi-model you know data
processing is something that we have
been speaking around a lot within the
past decade or so and I think this is
the moment that we'll be seeing more and
more with the you know llams and
generative AI Solutions helping us to
tap into the potential of the you know
particular unstructured data whether it
is tax or it comes in different forms as
well and I'd like to look ahead a little
bit with AI and you know the data
analytics as well so what do you believe
is the most exciting potential you know
application or AI that we have yet to
see right because you know we are seeing
a lot there's lots of noise as well it
is and
I'm sure that what we are speaking now
will not be what you know it is very
difficult to predict the future but you
know what do you think around that
yeah
um well I think personally I'm most
excited about solving uh the big
problems around uh you know the
intersection between people and
technology so around health education
and then sustainability as well
um so yeah I'm looking forward to you
know AI helping us to discover new drugs
uh create more tailored education
programs to really help get the best out
of people uh more accurately predict
floods and wildfires to help keep people
safe and uh you know changing
environment
yes I think I think there's a lot of
potential there to top intern and my
last question and you know biome is not
the least so uh we spoke a little bit
around it you know different type of
personas but what advice would you give
you are very experienced in this area to
individuals or other you know
organizations looking to prepare for
future rare really AI plays it you know
significant or more significant role you
know because if they don't get the value
and if if the competition comes and does
it before them it will be challenging
for them where do you see that where do
you see that did you know AI plays even
more role within the organizational
processes as well
yeah
um I would probably recommend by you
know starting to identify use cases uh
for you know organization where they
expect good Roi
um and then a relatively low risk and
you know you can brainstorm by tasks
that llms are good at such as search or
summarization generation rewriting and
then start experimenting
um I also there's a lot of tools right
now that make AI much more accessible
and so you know I would recommend to
think about the approach or mix of
approaches that you would want to take
and then hire accordingly so for example
you might use out of the box product
functionality to quickly build immersive
experiences for which you would need
application developers you might adapt
foundational models to your own needs
and to differentiate uh for which you
would need data scientists right or you
might even train and build your own
customized large models using
specialized AI infrastructure and for
that you would need you know ml
researchers and Engineers that are very
specialized
thank you yes and I agree actually it is
really a multi-objective optimization
problem at the end of the day whether
you should be building or whether you
should be you know buying the solutions
whether you should be using the
foundation or models or whether it
should be you know going and you're
developing your views and training years
whether you should bring your own data
sets or your existing data sets I think
there will be lots of things that we'll
see and organizations need to juggle
around as well but I think you are spot
on what are the key you know parameters
that gets you to you know the highest
Roi right and where you would get the
most value is the key thank you for
joining us Sona it has been incredible
to you know hear from you and we look
forward to seeing how AI will really
continue to shape the world around us
and hope our viewers will be inspired to
embrace its potential opportunities
thank you very much
thanks
foreign